[Musique]
c'est à petite île chez Monsieur
fontaine agriculteur que se sont rendus
Nassima dandar président du Département
Serge oirot conseiller départemental en
charge de l'agriculture et Michel
Fontaine sénateur et maire de
Saint-Pierre mon exploitation se compose
de 25 hactares de Cann et puis en
société avec paillette Jean-François les
ser et culture au sol que là oùù nous
sommes aujourd'hui les agriculteurs
présents ont ainsi fait part des
nombreuses difficultés qu'il rencontrre
tel que le manque de main d'œuvre ou
encore l'importation des produits ben
les difficultés il y en a énormément
c'est la
commercialisation la main d'œuvre et
aussi les produits phyo qu'onarrive pas
à trouver sur le marché donc tout ça
fait beaucoup d'éléments
c'est très difficile à gérer quoi
écoutez moi pour l'instant je fais que
je fais que du pleinchamp je suis je
suis pas soucer ni éleveur je fais du
marichchage diversifié le seul souci que
je rendc compte à l'heure actuelle je
suis un gros producteur de carotte moi
et ce qui minquiète un peu c'est les
importations de carotes quoi une matinée
sur le terrain qui a permis d'échanger
et d'appréhender les difficultés
auquelles sont confrontés les
producteurs ser agner au mieux les
agriculteurs réunionnés il est très
important pour nous de venir sur le
terrain à à la rencontre au fond des
vrais producteurs qui nous ont fait part
au fond des difficultés qu'ils
rencontent aujourd'hui sur le coût de
revien de certains produits comme la
tomate puisque nous sommes dans dans une
serre de de tomates et et le coût de
vente et et c'est vrai que il y a
aujourd'hui plein de paradoxes qui
existent en matière d'élevage comme en
matière d'aide sur les les filières
fruits légumes donc ce sont C ces
corrections que nous devons essayer
d'apporter au niveau des aides du
conseil départemental je pense qu'il y a
pas mal de choses à revoir pour r déjà
l'adaptation des normes européennes
l'adaptation des normes françaises sur
un territoire comme la région les
difficultés aussi avec l'urbanisation et
les teres agricoles aujourd'hui et sur t
celles qui peuvent encore être mises en
valeur là aussi un gros travail moi je
pense aussi c'est surtout sur
l'écoulement de la production agricole
sur la compétitivité de de leurs
produits où il faut véritablement agir
et je crois qu'ilgent sur toutes les
filières agricoles d'ailleurs le Conseil
départemental chef de fil de la
politique agricole à la Réunion soite
préserver l'agriculture rurale
réionnaise riche authentique et
diversifié aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas
moins de 52 dispositifs d' qui ont été
validés et qui sont désormais
[Musique]
actifs